ragatzu a ribelli so che vi è mancato
manca parkour quindi siamo all'episodio
buona visione cosa diavolo mi sa che
abbiamo pisciato un attimo fuori dal
vaso dici che bello posso vedere tutti i
livelli che abbiamo fatto
allora noi siamo partiti da lì poi che
ho fatto tutto questo ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta da tutti gli alberi pensiamo creativi
poi siamo arrivati qui abbiamo fatto un
65 per cento ma ti sono in totale ma non
è un conto a 210 x 10 09 us i 10 c
raccontare quello diplomato a bacon che
la torre ed occorre non è lui la torre
non è l'ultimo gradino
ma veramente è quanto pare il signor e
non dopo questo tipo ma sto malissimo
anche quindi questa era la parte più
alta e a quanto pare il city da 15 ma al
livello che figata è dovuta regioni dove
dorme questo è mai saltata saltate stata
mai un tuo amico ancora dove devo andare
ed ecco ma passa con design è arrivato
nell'altro parla altra parte di slime ti
slime sono qua amico è un attimo che non
sono ancora da vivere dove devo andare
qua devo ritornare a design di prima va
bene sono due livelli infatti di slime è
no non devi amico e non deve venire qua
forse ho capito devo uscire da qui di
fatto devo rifare tutto quanto ricorre
quindi si era capito anche se sì ti
facciamo
ciao ok lì e poi gli impasti sull'alto
livello e poi nel livello dopo capito
nel livello dopo questo ho beccato
l'unico blog come lo slime perfetto cioè
io sono arrivato vivi e belli si è stata
bellissima st parte geniale quarto del
secondo amico un attimo ci dissi ma
questo ai vini che ti voglio vedere
buttarti giù bravo l'unico amico poi
subito da me no è difficile se non me lo
stai sbagliando ha passato che ti
diverti più ampio forse ma gli amici
ciao
chissà che non riesce vi basta però
posso colpirti ma secondo fare ok grazie
va bene capisco devi venire qua sotto i
fari così occhio con i morti da zero no
no non è vero e io non ci faccio finta
di niente io far barbadori temerario che
noi o po troppo popolari fare anch'io
farò paurissima vinto meno male anche se
ti fai partire da no vabbè dai che
figata
dobbiamo farla sta roba oddio è arrivata
è arrivata la pioggia prima sopra e lo
avevo già sentita prima che toccasse
terra che figata
perché ti avevo ogni 5 minuti due volte
non lo so già fatta io no air da lì un
fenomeno già fatto amico qui devi
saltare su questi porti magari cose che
non mi piego si no non ho idea
aspetta che provo arrivare alla fine da
qua non lo fare fidate c'è un blocco è
visibile ma poi scusami una volta
arrivate ma poi non ho capito una volta
arrivato qua ma scusa ma io non ho
capito st parte prima deve saltare tipo
di far arrivare in fondo
provai a sinistra sugli occhi questi
subì così qua e là sopra fai doppio
salto di slime e arrivi alla fine ad
elica mente a ok chiaro ma si vada è
ormai ormai ci ha preso gusto
no no no no non è vero
eva vento né a miglia sono tutti i
livelli allora come si fa da qui è devi
fare quello che mi hai detto tu io ho
fatto quello che mi hai detto tu
benissimo e io sono tornato indietro con
un ebete bravissimo divertivi a farlo
con i livelli assolutamente è così
divertente che lo faccio un'altra volta
madonna wireless non ti tocca a voi e ti
ho tirato un pugno prima perché ti ho
visto ok a chi non solo che qui sono
arrivato mai bene bravissime a un numero
uno almeno finisci lo fanno per me è
difficilissimo a parte finale va beh
l'ho già fatta se ho fatto sul serio che
fa effetto non so se i fas il sito lo
giuro come si arriva alla fine però per
la porta mi comincia a porta
non ce la fa non c'è dice è fatto
bravo e dovete spiegarmi o salti no
vabbè però non penso e provaci tu perché
non prima io ma si sicuro che sia così
ti si fila t non si può fare ce l'ho
fatta amico ce l'ho fatta sono forte
sono forte io se io né meno ciao
vado avanti ma che belli si livelli
dell'erba c'è delle degli alberi aspetta
io ci sono
quando le voci devo scendere se devi
devi esatto poi c'è un minimo cioè un
seno sono idiota come la come questo
fiore qui guarda sapeva perso la fate è
facile ci riesce a fare la sua firma è
di parma per the ok va bene ognuno sui
piccoli problemi va bene effetto no ho
sbagliato o write
cosa sta roba ma mi sa che lì partire da
sotto wow che belli imperi livelli dove
devi partire da giu io devo andare qua
blu all'ultimo sliven perché devi farci
fare i giri con le scale attorno alle
cose che vi odio io di torca di una
barca e ce l'ho fatta
bravo devi scendere facendo partire dai
porca vacca guarda dove partorire poi fa
il giro del tronco cosa che non sono
ancora riuscito a fare perfetto poi salì
qui
no non è vero sono ancora in piedi
spetta perfetto
perfetto petto ma faceva corona ok
mamma mia che ansia amico dove vado qua
adesso non sai tu ce l'ho fatta vieni
ora che siamo secondi ormai si ci siamo
noi siamo skillati gioco è un macello
del macello non ha idea assolutamente
cosa dove dovrebbe portare scusa mincio
dell'ossidiana l'innocua c'è un punto
stranissimo non solo dovrebbe portare
mai nella vita non ci arrivi lei mara 5
arriva ma non ci puoi arrivare è
impossibile quando ci si può arrivare
mavava sei scemo per il credere 4 ma che
ci credo caruso 26 blocchi di distanza
ho fatto amico ballo ce l'ho fatta sul
serio a sia persa l'ossidiana adesso no
no no tua madre lebbrosa dai no dai non
è vero ha tempo capito ma va questi sono
scemi questo drogati forte fallo di
seguito fallo di seguito salta uno e
salta l'altro più facile grazie aspetta
aspetta la fine alla fine alla fine te
lo apro io vice al davis al talent
rossiniana complimenti complimenti per
la per la skill 12 6 si esce la tesi di
chi ruda pirla sì ma qua ma allora ma tu
puoi essere più mentecatto ti ho dato
una mano oppure ma cosa vuoi ma ti ho
portato una mano cosa uomini devi anche
il ma guarda che scemo 1 gli dà una mano
quello ma guarda li adori fare penso a
te non appassiona stati aiuto con un
dito nella nova che ti piacciono editi
nell'anno spero i pid ti tra l'altro di
italiani dgtvi dt nell'art
il carico era giusto qua è arrivato
altro per la scala è per fuorviare la
spalla la spa allora
asca ora erano eccola è un'altra cosa da
fare qui addirittura a forse per salire
il livello cioè per poi passare sopra
quarta fuck you tube no no va male alla
critiche sono stupido no no no sono
scemo nell'anima è bravo no ho un mio
dio è cosa hai visto surreal power nudo
oddio no grazie a dio e al povero suo
realtà ora che secondo me loro gente
quindi ragazzi questo era l'episodio 4
di minecraft harcourt
continueremo nel prossimo spero che vi
sia piaciuto cosa ci piace quanto mi
piace anche alla società comincia una
descrizione tu sapresti rischiate non
scegliamo forse avendo stay hungry stay
animals no spetta a tutti caciotti
dovrebbe ragazzi
[Musica]